[Orientalische Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute habe ich ein Rezept für euch, nach dem viele gefragt haben,
nämlich ein türkisches Fladenbrot, also Ramazan Pidesi.
Gerade zu Ramadan gibt es dann immer ganz große Fladenbrote,
auch mit viel Belag.
In der Türkei ist es wirklich eine Tradition,
dass man gerade zum Ramadan die Fladenbrote eben auch zubereitet.
Ihr könnt das ganze ohne oder mit Topping machen.
Jetzt gibt es erst einmal ein Grundrezept
und später noch eine aufgepimpte Version.
Für den Teig verwende ich 1/2 Würfel Hefe,
1 TL Zucker, jeweils 200 g Wasser und Milch,
650 g Mehl, 1 TL Salz, 1 Eiweiß und 100 g Sonnenblumenöl.
Die Hefe kann ich jetzt schon einmal im Wasser auflösen.
Das Wasser darf auch gern lauwarm sein, aber eben nicht zu heiß.
Jetzt kurz verrühren.
Jetzt könnt ihr auch den Teig entweder mit der Hand verkneten
oder mit der Küchenmaschine,
Hauptsache, ihr kneten ihn lang genug, also etwa 10 Minute.
Jetzt kommt alles in die Rührschüsse hinein, dann das Mehl dazu.
Ich lasse immer ein bisschen etwas übrig.
Salz, die Milch und zum Schluss das Eiweiß und das Öl.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr wollt,
könnt ihr hier auch gern schon ein bisschen Hitze mit darauf geben.
[Küchenmaschine]
Es kann auch sein, dass ihr 2 EL Mehl weniger braucht.
Es kommt nämlich immer darauf an, wie groß auch das Eiweiß war.
Deswegen lasse ich immer ein bisschen etwas übrig
und schaue, wie sich der Teig verhält.
Jetzt einfach 10 Minuten lang kneten
– entweder mit der Maschine oder mit der Hand.
[Musik]
So sieht der Teig jetzt aus, richtig gut!
Ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen Öl
- da könnt ihr wieder Sonnenblumen- oder auch Olivenöl nehmen,
gerade so ein bisschen für die Hände.
Der Teig sollte jetzt schön weich sein,
aber nicht mehr so sehr kleben.
Er darf wirklich weicher sein als normalerweise.
Viele denken aber auch immer,
sie müssen dann noch mehr Mehl dazufügen, muss man aber gar nicht.
Man muss wirklich nur auch lange genug kneten.
So ein bisschen klebrig darf es sein,
aber nicht so, dass man ihn nicht formen kann.
Jetzt einfach schön zu einer Kugel formen,
mit Öl einstreichen, dass die Oberfläche nicht trocknet
und dann abgedeckt 1 Stunde aufgehen lassen
oder gern auch 1/2 Stunde mit Hitze, also mit etwa 30-34°C,
entweder in der Kenwood-Maschine
oder im Backofen mit der Dampfgarfunktion z. B.
Dann trocknet die Oberfläche auch nicht aus.
Ich werde jetzt den gleichen Teig noch einmal zubereiten,
denn das wird jetzt das normale Fladenbrot
und das zweite wird das Deluxe Fladenbrot.
[Musik und Uhr]
Der Teig ist jetzt schön aufgegangen.
Hefeteig ist echt etwas für Schwaben – man macht ganz wenig hinein
und es kommt dann ganz viel heraus. [Lacht]
So, ein bisschen Öl.
Ihr könnt jetzt entweder 2 kleine oder ein großes Fladenbrot machen.
Ich muss sagen, so ein Ramazan Pidesi,
so ein richtiges Fladenbrot ist schon ein großes.
Daher jetzt wieder eine schöne Kugel formen.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt ein mittelgroßes Emaille-Blech,
gebe da etwas Öl hinein.
Da kommt der Teig hinein.
Jetzt könnt ihr den ein bisschen mit den Händen flach drücken.
Dann wird er jetzt noch einmal abgedeckt und darf ruhen,
damit er auch wirklich richtig schön luftig wird.
So mache ich das auch gleich mit der zweiten Teigportion
und kann aber schon die Zwischenzeit nutzen,
um die Kräuterfüllung für das zweite Brot zu machen,
was dann wirklich ein Deluxe Brot wird – Deluxe Fladenbrot.
Für die Käse-Kräuter-Variante verwende ich 20 g Butter,
1 Prise Zucker, 1 Knoblauchzehe, etwas Pfeffer, 1 Frühlingszwiebel,
bisschen Petersilie und Käse.
Ich verwende jetzt hier den Kaşar Käse,
weil er einfach von der Schmelzeigenschaft super ist.
Also ich möchte später, dass es so richtig Fäden zieht beim Schmelzen.
Daher nehme ich ihn.
Jetzt gebt ihr im Prinzip die Butter
- okay, ich hätte sie auch gleich in eine größere Schale geben können.
Den Knoblauch dazu.
Wenn ihr eine Knoblauchpresse verwendet,
müsst ihr ihn vorher nicht schälen.
Ihr könnt ihn einfach hier durchdrücken.
Und jetzt Achtung - das wurde mir vorhin beim Abtrocknen bewusst:
Aufmachen und er schabt es hier hinunter.
Etwas Pfeffer dazu, ein bisschen Zucker
und jetzt noch die Frühlingszwiebel und Petersilie feinhacken.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier kurz verrühren.
Das ist jetzt praktisch meine leckere Kräuterbutter.
Wenn ihr jetzt keine Lust darauf habt, sie selbst zu machen,
dann könnt ihr auch einfach eine fertige Kräuterbutter nehmen.
[Musik]
Den Käse schneide ich in Stifte.
Meistens halbiere ich ihn erst einmal.
Wenn ihr ihn besser schneiden wollt,
dann könnt ihr ihn auch kurz ins Gefrierfach stellen.
Dann ist er nämlich härter und lässt sich einfacher schneiden.
[Musik]
Jetzt zeige ich euch das traditionelle Fladenbrot.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt ein Eigelb und rühre ein bisschen Wasser hinein,
aber nicht zu viel – wirklich nur ganz wenig -,
dass es sich besser verrühren lässt.
Dann könnt ihr das hier so schön darüberstreichen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt die typische Fladenbrotoptik:
Entweder könnt ihr jetzt mit den Fingern praktisch
das Ganze so einteilen oder ihr nehmt eine Teigkarte
und macht ein Rautemuster hinein.
Ruhig bis nach unten bis zum Boden.
[Musik]
Gerne ein bisschen Schwarzkümmel und Sesam draufstreuen
und direkt im heißen Ofen backen.
Und dann kommt noch die zweite Version.
[Musik und Uhr]
[Musik]
Jetzt wird es ein bisschen knifflig,
denn jetzt nehmt ihr diese Kräuterbutter
und setzt sie mit dem Käse zusammen praktisch in die Rillen hinein.
Ich setze jetzt erst einmal die Butter drauf
und drücke sie mit dem Käse sozusagen in die Rille hinein.
[Musik]
Schön! Das kommt jetzt auch in den heißen Backofen.
Dann wird probiert.
Fladenbrot könnt ihr im Prinzip zu allem servieren,
zu jedem Hauptgericht – oder das Fladenbrot wird euer Hauptgericht.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind die Fladenbrote fertig.
Ich habe sie jetzt auch kurz in der Form gelassen.
Dann lassen sie sich perfekt lösen.
Man kriegt sie auch wirklich super gut aus der Form heraus.
Jetzt lasse ich den Rouven probieren.
Den habt ihr auch schon ab und zu in meinen Videos gesehen.
Herzlich willkommen.
ROUVEN: Hallo.
SALLY: Ich bin es gar nicht gewohnt, so große Menschen...
große Männer in der Küche zu haben [Beide lachen]
Josh, du hast auch die Kamera umstellen müssen, gell?
JOSH: Ja, ja! [Lacht] Ich dachte, der Murat kommt.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Nein, Spaß!
Ja, also ich habe hier einmal ein Fladenbrot
und ein Fladenbrot mit Kräuterkäse.
ROUVEN: Oh, lecker!
SALLY: Rouven macht bei uns immer das Smart Home System,
deswegen gerade drüben auf der Baustelle.
Auch hier hat er das Smart Home System gemacht.
Du bist Italiener, richtig?
ROUVEN: Ja, halb.
SALLY: Halbitaliener.
Eigentlich ist ja Fladenbrot und Focaccia schon ähnlich, gell?
ROUVEN: Ja.
SALLY: Der Unterschied – wahrscheinlich der Teig.
ROUVEN: Teig etwas, die Gewürze.
SALLY: Ja, die Focaccia wird auch nicht mit Eigelb bestrichen,
aber so vom Grundprinzip her ein großes Brot,
was schön luftig aufgeht.
Vor allem suchen wir nicht die Unterschiede beim Essen.
Wir suchen immer so richtig interkulturelle Verknüpfungen.
Wir suchen ja immer die Gemeinsamkeiten zwischen den ganzen Ländern.
Essen verbindet!
Ich würde sagen, das ist ja normales Fladenbrot,
was man zu allem essen kann – kann man auch füllen,
kann man toasten am nächsten Tag, kann man gut einfrieren.
Das hier ist schon The Special One!
ROUVEN: Auf jeden Fall!
SALLY: Also ich würde sagen, dass du das probierst,
aber ist leider schon ein bisschen kalt.
ROUVEN: Hmm!
SALLY: Eigentlich wäre es besser, wenn es warm wäre.
ROUVEN: Da habe ich doch etwas vorbereitet!
SALLY: Komm, hau rein!
ROUVEN: Aus der Werkzeugkiste.
SALLY: Das freut ihn jetzt, gell?
ROUVEN: Ja!
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Ein bisschen erwärmen.
ROUVEN: So machen wir das auf der Baustelle auch.
SALLY: Ach so, macht ihr euch so die Suppen warm?
ROUVEN: So machen wir das Essen warm.
SALLY: Ernsthaft?
ROUVEN: Manchmal, wenn es kalt ist, ja.
Bevor man so eiskalte Brötchen isst...
SALLY: Gewusst, wie.
ROUVEN: Was möchtest du haben?
SALLY: Komm, wir nehmen eins aus der Mitte heraus.
Okay, die kleine Palette ist gerade draußen.
Ich nehme die große.
[Heißluftfön]
Ich glaube, Sarah hat noch meine Paletten.
Bitte schön!
ROUVEN: Danke!
SALLY: Ich glaube, ich nehme auch eins.
ROUVEN: Super! Oh, das ist schon...
SALLY: Schon schön warm, ja!
ROUVEN: Super gut!
SALLY: Auch schön luftig.
Ich beiße jetzt aber nicht rein. Ich mach so.
ROUVEN: Mmh! Toll.
SALLY: Oh, ich habe Salz in der Kräuterbutter vergessen.
In der Kräuterbutter fehlt Salz.
ROUVEN: Stimmt, ein Ticken Salz.
SALLY: Ein bisschen, ja.
Ich habe vorhin noch daran gedacht, aber meine Hände waren schmutzig
und dann wollte ich die Salzmühle nicht anfassen.
Dann habe ich nicht mehr daran gedacht.
Also ein bisschen Salz an die Kräuterbutter.
Aber so, gell?
ROUVEN: Oh ja!
SALLY: Schön luftig. Ach perfekt!
ROUVEN: Guter Biss!
SALLY: Ja! Am besten ganz heiß aus dem Ofen essen.
Ihr habt ja an den Bildern gesehen...
Dann ist es schön warm, der Käse fließt und zieht.
Das ist sehr, sehr gut.
Also falls ihr das Fladenbrot nachmachen wollt
- egal, ob pur, also Natur, oder mit Kräuterbutter und Käse -,
probiert es gerne aus.
Falls ihr es nachmacht, macht ein Foto und postet es auf Social Media.
Dann kann ich es nämlich auch sehen und kommentieren.
Ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
Vielleicht bereitet ihr es jetzt noch zum Ramadan zu.
Das Rezept findet ihr, wie immer, auf Sallys-Blog.de.
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
Neuer Untertitel
SALLY: Willst du das einmal nachmachen?
ROUVEN: Das? [Sally stimmt zu]
Hmm, das wird mir nicht gelingen.
SALLY: Ach Quatsch! Doch, mit der Anleitung von mir gelingt das!
ROUVEN: Ich habe die Geduld nicht mit dem Teig, den so lange...
SALLY: Hefeteig?
ROUVEN: ... gehen zu lassen.
SALLY: Echt? [Rouven stimmt zu]
Aber kurz geknetet, halbe Stunde aufgehen.
ROUVEN: Bei mir ist es immer Emotion:
Ich habe dann Lust, etwas zu machen und kann dann nicht so
„Okay, jetzt warte ich auf den Teig – so eine halbe Stunde!“
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Okay. Na dann!
ROUVEN: Aber die anderen Sachen mache ich schon gern!
SALLY: Gell?
ROUVEN: Ja, ja!
SALLY: Was hast du zuletzt nach meinem Rezept nachgemacht?
ROUVEN: Was war das letzte, was ich nach deinem Rezept gemacht habe?
Ich glaube, das war der Geburtstagskuchen.
SALLY: Der Guinness-Kuchen? Nein.
ROUVEN: Nein. Ich weiß nicht mehr. Einfach ein ganz einfacher
Schokokuchen.
Oder wie heißt er?
SALLY: Ah, der zarte Schokoladenkuchen. [Rouven stimmt zu]
Der alte da.
ROUVEN: Den liebt er ja. Den liebt mein Sohn.
SALLY: Ach schön. Seht ihr: Backen verbindet!
Tschüss.
ROUVEN: Ciao.
[Musik]